نعود لتطورات الميداليه في اوكرانيا
وتحديدا اعلام كيف اسقاط صاروخ روسي تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت باربعه اضعاف نتحدث عن
الصاروخ كنجال يعني الخنجر باللغه الروسيه
هو احد سته اسلحه من الجيل القادم كشف
عنها الرئيس الروسي عام 2018
ترافقا مع الاعلان قال بوتين حينها ان
صاروخ فنجان كي اتش 47 سلاح مثالي يصعب
جدا على الدفاعات الصاروخيه ان تعترضه
انجال هو الصاروخ البالسكي الذي يطلق من
الجو ويمكن ان تصل سرعته الى 12
الفا350 كيلو مترا في الساعه وقادر على
حمل رؤوس حربيه نوويه او تقليديه وتشير
التقارير لان مداه يتراوح بين 1500 الى
2000 كيلومتر قائد سلاح الجو الاوكراني
كشف ان الصاروخ الروسي الذي تم اسقاطه
اطلق خلال هجوم روسي على كيف ومدن اخرى
الساعات الاولى اليوم الخميس
يعني ذلك ان الهجوم جاء بعد اقل من يوم
واحد من اتهام روسيا لاوكرانيا بتنفيذ
محاوله فاشله لاغتيال فلاديمير بوتين
الرئيس الروسي في هجوم بطائره مسيره على
مبنى الكرملين وهدرت بالرده لكن كيف اسقط
كينجا
تلاحظوا الجو الاوكراني يقول ان منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه هي التي اسقطت
الصاروخ الروسي يعود تصنيع نواه منظومه
الى سته عقود لانها ككثير من انواع
الاسلحه لها طرازات وعجال حديثه ومن اطراز
باك ثري ام اس اي ذو القدرات العاليه ايضا
هو عباره عن نظام صاروخ ارجو تصنعه شركه
ريثيون الامريكيه ومصمم للحمايه من
الصواريخ المهاجمه والطائرات اذ يقوموا
باسقاطها وتفجيرها في الهواء قبل ان تبلغ
اهدافها هذا الصاروخ له منظومه رادار
فتمكن من رصد 50 هدفا في ان واحد وفي خلال
تسع ثوان فقط يمكنها ان تسقط هذه الاهداف
تسع ثواني من وصول الاشاره الى غرفه
التحكم يمكنها ان تسقط هذه الاهداف في
نطاق يمتد من 60 مترا الى 15
مترا في السنه